A lot goes into rating a film.
The Motion Picture Association of America
thoroughly reviews upcoming releases to see
if they contain content generally deemed inappropriate
for younger audiences.
Dirty jokes, mature themes, graphic violence,
and gratuitous nudity can all earn a film
an R rating, letting parents know they probably
don't want to bring the whole family.
For the most part, this system works well,
but it definitely isn't perfect - as highlighted
by these standout cases of super scary movies
that somehow avoided an R rating.
Ouija: Origin of Evil
From director Mike Flanagan, 2016's Ouija:
Origin of Evil reveals the blood-chilling
events that occurred before the first Ouija
film.
It follows single mom Alice as she runs a
sham psychic business out of her home with
her daughters Paulina and Doris.
When Alice brings a Ouija board into the mix
in an effort to liven up her act with some
supernatural flair, the three women unwittingly
make contact with an evil spirit.
Ouija: Origin of Evil shies away from gore,
but it maintains a constant sense of dread,
delivering violent deaths, a freaky demonic
possession, and enough horrifying images to
keep you wide awake at night.
Just like we couldn't believe this prequel
was actually a solid film following its vapid
predecessor, we're also stunned it snuck into
theaters without an R rating.
"And the last thing you feel is cold."
Mama
2013's Mama stars Jessica Chastain as Annabel
and Nikolaj Coster-Waldau as her boyfriend
Lucas and follows Lucas' young nieces, Victoria
and Lilly, and the ghostly figure they call
"Mama" that looms over them.
When Lucas and Annabel bring Victoria and
Lilly home after they spent five years in
isolation following their mother and father's
deaths, Mama extends her monstrous maternal
hand beyond the girls' reach to grip the lives
of those around them.
Mama's eerie imagery, tense and terror-filled
story, and haunting ending gives us a case
of the heebie-jeebies usually reserved for
R-rated fare.
How it skated by on a PG-13 instead, we'll
never fully understand.
[spooky monster groaning]
Insidious
Patrick Wilson and Rose Byrne lead 2010's
Insidious as married couple Josh and Renai
Lambert, who recently moved into a new home
with their three children.
What should be a humble abode instead becomes
the center of their nightmares as really bad
things begin to befall the Lamberts.
It all starts when Josh and Renai's son Dalton
slips into a coma-like state after he sees
a figure hiding in the attic, and it only
gets worse from there.
After Renai is attacked and a bloody handprint
is left on Dalton's bed, the Lamberts pack
up and move to a new house - but the spirits
haunting them persist.
A demonic, Darth Maul-looking entity stalks
the family of five, and viewers soon learn
the real reason for Dalton's unconsciousness
and the startling truth behind Josh's identity.
Insidious is light on blood and guts, but
heavy on creepy imagery, psychological tension,
and unsettling storylines, which is why it's
so surprising that it didn't receive an R
rating.
[Demonic roar]
"It's here!"
The Last Exorcism
How did The Last Exorcism, the found-footage
possession pic that's appeared on many a "scariest
horror films" list slip by with a PG-13 rating?
This genuinely eerie 2010 film begins with
Reverend Cotton Marcus embarking on what he
thinks will be a routine fake exorcism he's
grown used to performing.
Here's just a taste of what then goes down:
there's face slashing, animal killing, and
finger breaking.
There are horrifying hooded figures, decapitations,
and people getting burned alive.
And, of course, there's a possessed girl who
contorts into a human pretzel and fills an
already eerie barn with the sounds of her
strained, demonic voice.
"We're gonna go now, we're gonna get you in
the car…"
[Scream]
"Are you okay?"
Drag Me to Hell
Director Sam Raimi returned to his horror
roots with 2009's Drag Me to Hell.
The film begins as mild-mannered bank loan
officer Christine Brown turns down her client
Sylvia's request for yet another mortgage
extension.
On the verge of eviction, Sylvia crawls into
the back seat of Christine's car, then attacks
and places a curse on her.
Now haunted by a soul-starved spirit, Christine's
life spirals into a blood-soaked horror show.
She imagines flies buzzing in her stomach,
experiences a projectile nosebleed, takes
part in a demonic goat sacrifice, jumps into
a grave to dig up a corpse, and gets embalming
liquid pumped into her mouth via a dead person's
vomit.
Featuring some of the most ferociously gruesome
gags in recent memory, Drag Me to Hell is
a hammy but horrifying splatter-fest that
is somehow not rated R.
The Ring
2002's The Ring is intensely terrifying with
a weird concept: watch a VHS tape and die
seven days later.
It's only made odder and more unsettling by
helmer Gore Verbinski's off-kilter directorial
choices.
Dead bodies and the disturbing videotape connect
a handful of Pacific Northwest teenagers to
journalist Rachel Keller, who ventures to
find out the truth behind the killings and
see if she can escape the unavoidable.
The entire film is filled with grisly images,
most notably drowned ghost Samara Morgan emerging
from a TV screen and staggering across the
floor.
There's also a horse getting chopped to pieces
by the blades of a ferry propeller, plus some
disembowelment and ripped-up fingernails for
good measure.
What ultimately pushes The Ring into should-be-R-rated
territory is its continuous sense of terror
and persistent disturbing imagery that leave
you with a feeling of dread you just can't
shake.
"Oh my God, Katie…
You freak!"
Jaws
This 1975 Steven Spielberg classic sees a
gung-ho group of guys journey into the big
blue in search of the man-eating great white
shark that's been terrorizing beachgoers on
Amity Island.
Things go just about as well as you'd anticipate
they would in a shark-hunting venture.
The inclusion of many brutal fatalities and
the explosive shark death makes Jaws completely
inappropriate for the tame PG rating it was
given.
Even though the MPAA had, at the time, only
PG or R to pick when rating Jaws, the clear
choice should have been the latter.